digitalität als lernkultur setzt voraus
dass man sich zunächst einmal gedanken
über das lernen an sich macht
bildungsprozesse unter den bedingungen
von digitalität entstehen nicht
automatisch teurer in der
digitalisierung von räumen oder unter
verwendung bestimmter digitale werkzeuge
oder programme sie mir geht es um eine
grundlegende veränderung von lernkultur
wir müssen kindern gelegenheiten geben
sich sinnvoll zu vernetzen
mit menschlichen und nicht menschlichen
akteuren zu kommunizieren zu
kollaborieren kreativ zu sein produkte
zu präsentieren und zu teilen und
letztendlich sie dann zu unterstützen
sich in einer digitalisierten welt
zurechtzufinden und diese zu verstehen
vor allem aber auch aktiv daran
teilzuhaben und im unterricht stellt
sich gar nicht so sehr die frage ob
analog oder digital
vielmehr geht es um eine sinnvolle
verknüpfung von inhalt methode und
medium